[Music]
when you're a kid
i think the universe revolves around you
you think that you'll always be
protected and cared for
then one day you realize that's not true
because when you're alone as a kid
the monsters see you as weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer
[Music]
till it's too late
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed
that all the bad things that happen in
this town are because of one thing
an evil thing
bill if you'll come with me you'll float
[Music]
i saw something a clown yeah i saw him
too
what happens when another georgie goes
missing
or one of us
are you just gonna pretend it isn't
happening like everyone else in this
town
if we stick together
[Music]
[Music]
my grandfather thinks this town is
cursed he says that
all the bad things that happen in this
town are because of one thing
an evil thing that feeds off the people
of dairy
but it can't be one thing we all saw
something different
maybe or maybe it knows what scares us
most and that's what we see
i i saw a leper you
he was like a walking infection but you
didn't
because it isn't real none of this is
none of this makes any sense
they're all like bad dreams i don't
think so i know the difference between
a bad dream in real life okay
we're all afraid of something got that
right
why rich what are you afraid of
clowns
guys
don't tell me that's no
good look george you were galoshes
whose sneaker is it
it's betty rips what if she's still here
eddie come on my mom will have an
aneurysm okay if you find something that
we're playing down here i'm serious
bill if
if i was betty ripson i would want us to
find him
georgie too what if i don't want to find
them
i mean no offense build it i don't want
to end up like
i don't want to go missing either
[Music]
hi georgie
what a nice boat do you want it back
um yes please you look like a nice boy
do you want a balloon to a georgie i'm
not supposed to take stuff from
strangers
oh well i'm pennywise dancing clown
now we aren't strangers are we
i should get going now
without you bow
[Music]
there you go she's already captain
thanks billy
[Music]
no
there's not like any town i've ever been
in before
people tired disappear six times the
national average
and that's just grown-ups kids are worse
way way worse
i saw something there was this
a clown
yeah i saw him too
look it's all connected by the sewers
that's where it lives
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
bill if you'll come with me you'll float
too
you'll float too you will do
[Music]
[Music]
oh that was awesome
that was really scary
[Music]
i think i blew out my vocal cords i'm
screaming so loud
mom's i screamed a lot
they don't know which one's which and
then
that scared me
check it out because it's a really cool
maze to go through
when you're a kid i think that you'll
always
be protected cared for we like hanging
with you
thanks you shouldn't think it's too much
hanging out with us makes you a loser
too
but when you're alone as a kid
[Music]
the monsters see you is weaker
you don't even know they're getting
closer until it's too late
where's the poison ivy nowhere okay well
i'm starting to get itchy
i'm pretty sure this is not use the same
bathroom as your mother sometimes yeah
then you probably have crabs that's so
not funny
aren't you guys coming in uh-uh it's
great water what the hell is gray water
it's basically piss and [ __ ] so i'm just
telling you
you guys are splashed around in millions
of gallons of dairy pee
so are you serious what do you doesn't
smell like coca-cola
have you ever heard of a staph infection
also yes this is so
unsanitary you're literally this is
little are swimming inside of a toilet
bowl right now you're the reason why
we're in this position right now
who's sneaker is it it's petty
what if she's still here
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
you